le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
parler des femmes s'est d'abord laissé
parler les femmes depuis 14 ans à
l'occasion de la journée de la femme le
conseil départemental attribue le prix
célimène un concours de créativité
destiné aux femmes artistes amateurs
dans les disciplines de la peinture de
la sculpture et de la photographie en
2016 anne béguin et lauréate de sa
catégorie
deux ans après elle fait le bilan de
cette aventure
[Musique]
le thème sur lequel je travaille en ce
moment c'est la végétation 20 ans
qu'anne mélange les couleurs au gré de
son imagination
ce matin c'est un lieu oublié que son
pinceau ramène à la vie
ces tableaux c'est en fait c'est le
château de heaulme qui se trouvait à
basse terre près de saint pierre en fait
j'ai trouvé ça sur un petit dépliant sur
l'habitat créole recréer ce lieu qui
n'existe plus anne est enseignante la
peinture n'est encore réservé qu'à ses
moments de loisirs
mais après une première tentative en
2015 la peintre amatrices décide de
retenter sa chance au concours célimène
organisée par le département de voir
tout ce que tout ce qui peut être
produit tout ce que peuvent faire les
femmes à la réunion en arts visuels et
se mélangent là je vais en
participer créé il ya 14 ans par le
département
le prix célimène a pour objectif de
valoriser les femmes artistes amateurs
alors quel que soit le domaine que sur
la sculpture que ce soit la peinture
en tout cas c'est le but c'est vraiment
d'amener les femmes à s'exprimer à
travers leur créativité et cette année
comme l'année dernière nous avons ouvert
aussi le prix célimène aux jeunes
collégiens et cette opération bien sûr
et ouvert à toutes les femmes
et bien sûr ce sont des artistes
amateurs mais qui ont besoin d'un coup
de pouce pour se faire connaître et
montrer quelles sont leurs talents
édition 2016
cette fois c'est le talent dan qui
interpelle son oeuvre
le repos remporté le grand prix dans sa
catégorie c'est une femme africaine
[Musique]
transportent des bassines très très
lourde est en fait à un moment à
s'allonger à s'opposent sur cette base
il était ce moment particulier
d'épuisement que je voulais mettre en
valeur l'artiste a remporté trois mille
euros
mais c'est surtout le partage et la
reconnaissance qui lui ont permis
d'évoluer
on a toutes des choses à dire on a tous
des sensibilités différentes
il faut les partager en fait il faut les
partager et lorsque vous remettez vos
oeuvres à la maison justement du
département on accueille tout toutes
sortes toutes sortes d'oeuvres quoi il
n'y a pas de jugement ou reçoit on met
en valeur ce que vous avez produit
[Musique]
encouragé par ce prix anne continue de
peindre en se laissant porter par ses
impressions ses sensations un visage
croisé au hasard de la vie à la réunion
ou ailleurs j'aime beaucoup peindre les
portraits et des portraits de de gens de
la vie ordinaire qu'on peut rencontrer
cette femme en fait une femme sera
marché elle a l'air de penser les choses
qui lui appartiennent et j'avais envie
de saisir ce moment
le concours a permis à la peintre
amatrice de s'affirmer dans son art pour
la première fois anne prépare un grand
projet pour 2018
puis le prix célimène je me suis dit que
j'allais me lancer dans une exposition
je suis partie justement de la
végétation qu'on peut trouver à la
réunion là dans mon environnement il ya
des tas de plantes que j'ai en eux et
j'ai eu envie de mettre en scène
donc ces tableaux parlent de la réunion
par le paysage parle de lieux qui ont
disparu pour celui ci je me suis
inspirée d'une lithographie deroussen et
cette femme devant devant cette maison
peut-être réfléchir à son histoire quoi
l'histoire de son de son pays de son
peuple face à sa propre expérience c'est
avec sérénité et optimisme que l'artiste
fait le bilan
tu me suis rendu compte qu'en fait c'est
important de montrer son travail qu' il
ne faut pas avoir peur du jugement
les personnes et que à certaines
personnes ça va plaire à d'autres ça va
déplaire mais peu importe l'essentiel
c'est de de toucher les gens la peinture
comme la sculpture comme la photographie
c'est une vision qu'on a du monde à
travers sa sensibilité et puis
il faut l'exprimer la partager
le prix célimène est un concours
organisé par le département pour
valoriser les femmes et les collégiens
artistes amateurs dans les domaines de
la peinture la sculpture et la
photographie
il s'adresse aux femmes de plus de 18
ans résidant à la réunion sans formation
artistique
n'ayant jamais participé à une
exposition depuis deux ans le concours
s'ouvre aussi aux collégiens et
collégiennes vous souhaitez vous
inscrire à l'édition 2018
dépêchez vous de vous rendre sur le site
du département au www.cn.ca 4 point fr
clôture des inscriptions le 15 février
[Musique]